okay so seeing how this is like one of
the last DVDs and pranking me with the
nostalgia critic on it probably I
decided to actually look around and show
you where the nostalgia critic was
originally shot at just Circo over where
it all started this is actually where it
all started and you're probably seeing
yourself wow that doesn't look like the
nostalgia critic serie at all and why
did he have all this stuff up well truth
be told this is something I want to keep
it secret for a while because I was
embarrassed before but honestly I was
living with my parents when I started
all of this diacritic thing which was
like the one thing I was trying to keep
really high highs for a long time which
is not like a huge embarrassment or
anything but at the same time just I
didn't always make the best financial
decisions back then so when I was
starting this up and it was doing well
it just always sounded bad to say oh
yeah yeah no I I have this website then
I do comedy on where you live with my
parents you know it just never sounded
good so with that said what is this room
this is actually a massage room you can
even see there's the massage table and
this is actually what I used as the
nostalgia critic stable and the great
thing about that is nostalgia critic
often times would slam his head whoop
I'm dark there we go
nostalgic would often slam his head into
the table well you can do it on this
table because it's a very soft table and
with this stuff what I used to do this
with drive my folks nuts I would just
take this move over to the side take the
board side take down all those things
and my folks are still actually really
mad at me because at one point when I
put a green screen up because they used
to set the green screen room and left
that mark and I should probably pay for
someone to come in and fix that because
that was my fault but this is
essentially you can can see the room and
there's uh there's music for the massage
table you know when my mother gives
massages because like I said she's a
masseuse and this is really where all
the stuff happened and if she can
probably see her maybe you can't it's a
it's not a huge room it was never that
big but
but that's also why in some earlier
videos you might see some of those
flowers PE every once in a while or like
that picture I think would peek in every
once in a while you're not looking at my
biggest enemy when I began filming that
little event the air conditioning used
to be my biggest enemy because like an
idiot when I started out I would forget
to turn the air conditioning off so
again if you look at some of the earlier
videos here love you in the background
or sometimes the audio doesn't match up
you know like it sounds clear but that's
silly ya know in the background that's
why it was that I got nobody to blame
but myself that's my own fault but this
is where I shot all my NC so let's go to
where I actually edited them I'm right
again alright so this used to be my room
but not only that it was also my editing
room now this is a different computer
obviously and my dad now uses it to
compose music but as you can see this is
where the computer used to be and
there's a new one there now and I used
to do all my editing where I slept which
I'm gonna tell you right now is not a
smart idea I'll tell you exactly why cuz
a lot of times when you get up and
you're okay go to work go to work when
that bed is there and you're tired man
it's it's pretty friggin tempting you
take a lot more naps than you need to
the other thing about is that when
you're trying to sleep and then the
computers right there it's a I wanna
work or maybe I should edit those who
manage to get this done that can get in
the way so if you actually do end up if
you're fortunate enough to work from
home don't put your workspace in the
same place that you sleep cuz it will
mess you up alright or you just will not
have a normal flow going there's my
brother and I when were kids Oh Nicky
I'm the one on the left you can tell by
got my forehead was big even back then
look at that
yeah well anyway okay now I'm going to
show you something else that I should
have repaired okay you see this dent
here I don't know if you can quite make
it up it's about the size of a fist
okay well that should give you some idea
of what that is um excuse my voice by
the way okay so what that is that back
in the old days what
I was still getting used to the computer
I didn't know much about computers uh
some stuff would go missing like some
files would disappear because I wouldn't
put them in the right place or the cache
files would build up and then they
couldn't connect and the auto-saves
wouldn't always work you know again
because we didn't have enough storage
and this is back in the early days you
make mistakes but a lot of times that
ended up and resulting in the losing of
hours and hours of work well I'm pretty
even-tempered I'm you know a lot of
people say I'm laid back and then nice
and stuff but if something goes wrong
with work I freak I get like really
friggin angry at one point I remember
the exact review it was it was the
pagemaster and I lost like an hour of
work like an hour work gone I had to do
it all over again I was already behind
on this and I got so mad I punched a
hole in the wall that's what this is
boom right there I mean okay so it's not
like through the wall as you can see but
what I used to do is I used to just put
a calendar there to cover it up but yeah
they decided to just leave it there when
you're doing that because we were going
to hang a plaque there that said at this
place in what was I think it's in July
2005 Doug lost it and there's the proof
that I lost it and we'd still make jokes
about even to this day that's my dad by
the way by the way you should let them
know that that's also one of your set
pieces over there yeah the first episode
of demo reel we shot in here yeah I
forgot that's right the Teddy Ruxpin
thing was wasn't there now I gotta say I
didn't choose I didn't choose this day
corps I chose the American flags what is
up with the American flags that is your
aunt Bonnie who said let me redecorate
this room for Doug and he will
absolutely love it's frigging everywhere
look at it it's like it's even the lamp
is like that yeah even the friggin clock
isn't
American flag and I never really got why
I thought you guys just flipped her
something no that was her idea to sort
of make this room something you could be
proud oh well it certainly is very
patriotic okay now this is the upstairs
this is actually where Rob used to be
and as you can see we still haven't
taken down half this stuff because we're
terrible people but thinkin nobody
really comes up here anyway but this was
obviously the set for the executor we
didn't film that much up here except for
that one bit the executor but Rob's bed
used to be oh come on everyone's bed
used to be over there I have on
automatic by the way cut the lighting
has drastically changed and yeah these
were made by Jim Jay rods and you know a
lot of us come down now but we have no
time to oh I'm sorry Jimin is a lovely
wife well I I was just gonna get to I
was gonna get to that when we got
downstairs because we're gonna show the
downstairs said to all right but yeah we
really clean this up shouldn't we what
we white man I met Robin of yes and no
no he's done and speaking of still
having not cleaned up you can see a lot
of this stuff is still here as well as
just some other stuff now this actually
used to be before I moved into the room
upstairs this was sort of my area I
actually was straight up in my parents
basement and this actually used to be
where I slept here hold on let me turn
this light on like I said is that you
the robotoid outfit that still here the
blueprint for the blue she'll still get
that and the dream machine and I know
yeah so weird you still got a bunch of
stuff you know
eBay something pretty good right now but
yeah so she can see here we got a pretty
you know that this was pretty much where
I used to sleep out actually still the
bed that they used to sleep on there and
obviously just storage any bit of junk
or whatever that people just add lying
around they just threw in here and then
the basement here like it's a we use
this to shoot to bully flee because
it was a lot of space um like I said I
mean there's still some stuff here
there's still part of the set that uh J
Roz bill Stowe I still got the chair
there and now focus focus and that
little sign that's where the title
actually came from we didn't come up
with the title and then do the sign we
actually did the sign first
that's a beautiful sign who made that
one that must have been me Dan Jim
zeroes discredit you on the DVD and yeah
and I don't think that was there that we
probably moved that's also engineering
which I'm sure it also has some leftover
stuff oh not too much okay
there's still that one computer from
like 1982 or something like super super
old oh it was this stuff in there too
yeah just all that look how old all this
yeah so pretty much just a storage
room but it worked really well as the
well for what is the engine room slash
storage room in the area where we put
the mushrooms and stuff was really just
like the heating system and in a file
canned and that was pretty much I
windchill puts the mushroom and that's
where it went so yeah like I said I mean
nothing spectacular or anything but a
lot of people always wonder you know
where did you fill most of it how's the
room look and so I think the biggest
funny thing is the massage room because
it's just so different looking there's
actually stuff all over the walls so um
alright closing comments dad hey it's
wonderful having you here we do miss you
tremendously don't move back nice